[Narrator] And the answer is 0.0777 approximately,
and the way to obtain this is
for this particle to never to be drawn in the resampling phase.
We always have to draw 1 of the following 4 particles.
Those together have a probability of 0.6 to be drawn,
which contrasts to the 0.4 for P3.
So for 5 independent samplings to draw 1 of those 4,
we get a total probability of 0.6 to the fifth,
which is approximately 0.0777.
Put differently, there is about a 7.7% chance that this particle over here is missing,
but with almost 93% probability we'd have this particle included.
If we had, instead of P3, gone for P1 over here,
which has a much smaller probability of being drawn,
then this 0.07 will be as large as 0.59,
which is 0.9 to the fifth.
Now this means with about 60% chance
we will lose particle 1, and only with a 40% chance it will include it.
Put differently, the particles with small importance weights
will survive at a much lower rate than the ones with larger importance weights,
which is exactly what we wish to get from the resampling step.